um I'm going go with Buffalo I'm going
go with Buffalo to give Miami they first
loss today um I'm going go with the
Vikings getting that first win today bur
Carolina in in in Charlotte
um I'm going take Denver I'm going take
Denver uh so I got to go and of course
I'm going to go uh with my Cleveland
Browns uh to win that game but I'm going
to go with Pittsburgh um Pittsburgh just
um you know they're just very good you
know but I'm going to go with the Rams
I'm going to go with the Rams I'm out
here in La man I'm going to go with the
Buccaneers I'm going go with the
Buccaneers versus Saints you know in the
Super Dome I'm going to go with the
Eagles in that matchup um I'm going go
with Tennessee this week I got Tennessee
uh pulling that game out I got the
Chargers um evening in their record two
and two um beating the Raiders I got
Dallas winning the game uh I got the
Niners winning that game I got the
Chiefs winning that game very very
handily um